so i want to invite you guys
into contemplation
i want to invite you
into the endless summer
i want to invite you
into the golden hour veneer
i went to god
just to see
and i was looking at me
i want to invite you
into transitory enchanted moments
in which you hold your breath
compelled
into aesthetic contemplations you barely
understand face to face
with something
couldn't measure it
to your capacity
for wonder
you see these transitory enchanted
moments
they heal our fractures
they mend our brokenness
they jolt us
into awakening
they shake us
to the core
they make us
open our eyes
they cast away our sins and cleanse us
in an act of ecstatic absolution
we are transformed
we are reborn
[Music]
we are awakened from the lethargy of
custom in the film
of familiarity and redirected towards
the wonders of existence tom duty said
it best
we recontextualize the self as a
marvelous conduit in a timeless whole
from which molecules and meanings flow
from neurons to nebula
and back again
and in these moments
we grasp for language we grasp
for the words to mouth the ineffable to
map
the terrain the territory beyond the
maps that which shall not be named
faulkner speaks
of the writer's futile yet noble efforts
to fit the world in a sentence but we
try
in spite
of its futility we try
we do not go quietly into that good
night we rage against the dying of the
light whereas once we were blind
now we can see and william blake perhaps
he said it best
to see the world in a grain of sand
to see heaven
and a wild flower
to hold infinity
in the palms of our hand
to hold eternity
in an hour
[Music]
come with me
we shall see
it's a world
of pure imagination
[Music]
the curtain parts
and what had never been seen
is devoured by the eyes
it's distinct
abrupt framed
it is already a memory
it's a parting of the seas moment
you are jolted
into aliveness
it's characterized by heightened
qualitative intensity the mystery
beckons the curtain parts and what had
never been seen
is devoured by the eyes
the search is what anyone would
undertake send walker percy if we were
not sunk in the everydayness of our
lives
to become aware of the possibility of
the search
is to be on to something
and not to be onto something is to be in
despair
and as david foster wallace wrote the
alternative is unconsciousness the
default setting
the rat race
the constant gnawing sense
of having had and lost
some infinite thing
[Music]
i do not want to lose
this infinite thing
i will not go quietly into that good
night i will rage
against the dying of the light and maybe
it's an act of utility
and maybe
it is beyond our capacity
and all the clocks in the city
began to whirr and chime
let not time deceive you you cannot
conquer time
and headaches and in worries vaguely
life leaks away and time will have its
fancy tomorrow
or today said w.h
auden
but he is wrong
we don't read and write poetry because
it's cute we read and write poetry
because we are members of the human race
and the human race is filled with
passion
science engineering business technology
these are noble pursuits necessary to
sustain life but poetry truth freedom
romance
these are the things we stay alive for
these
are the things we stay alive
for
uh
oh
[Music]
oh
just feel it
just feel it
[Music]
i want that video
for myself
wow
oh thanks bro thanks